est ce que vous savez quel est le lien
entre un bandeau de bus une politique de
déneigement municipal et le temps alloué
à un feu piéton
avant de partager les secrets de
l'univers laissez moi d'abord remettre
en contexte
j'ai toujours été principalement une
automobiliste premièrement parce que
l'idée de me payer une voiture prenait
un travail qui servira environ le tiers
du temps payer une voiture ne m'a jamais
particulièrement séduite mais
principalement parce que j'ai le
souvenir très vif de mon père temple de
m'apprendre à conduire en faisant
changer de voie sur un pont d'une grande
artère de sherbrooke et devant mon
incompétence redouble de commentaires
passif agressif jusqu'au moment où je
réalise que la meilleure
la seule solution c'est de quitter
l'automobile j'avais donc et el motor
laissant mon père côté passager dans la
voie de gauche sur le pont pour quitter
sans jamais me retourner
cette étude de notre mobilité m'a
toujours rendu la vie plus douce mais
moi aussi fait vivre une panoplie titue
à sion que j'ai longtemps pensé comme
étant normal j'ai toujours pensé que
tout le monde garde et ses écouteurs
même sans musique lorsqu'ils marchaient
le soir pour revenir à la maison à la
fois pour avoir l'air occupé est assis
poli pour ne pas répondre aux inconnus
qui nous interpellait j'ai toujours
pensé que c'était normal de faire des
détours à pied peu importe le temps que
ça pouvait prendre pour continuer de
rester sur des rues fréquentées
achalandé et éclairé le sport venu en
tant que passagère des transports en
commun j'ai vite assimilé que j'allais
prendre une toute petite place sur mon
banc pendant que la mamie côté
confortablement prenait un bain et demi
pratique en 2022 est si répandue qu'elle
répond au doux nom de mendy trading vous
comprendrez que j'ai rapidement au prix
pour le vélo mais aucun mode de
transport n'est parfait et comme tout
les cyclistes je me suis habitué à me
faire crier de temps à autre des bêtises
par rapport à ma tenue
à ma simple présence sur la route à ma
façon de pédaler
j'ai même déjà reçu une demande en
mariage dans les districts de
l'hôtel-dieu au coin des rues papineau
mairie et king 1 mercredi matin alors
que nous on va travailler très tôt et
que certains genres entre temps de fêter
et de la fenêtre de son honda civic de
me lancer de manière poétique
podium de tizi quitter bella matin parce
que moi je demanderais à rien 7 marie
demande que j'ai malheureusement dû
décliner donc certes j'étais d'accord
que c'était un peu inconfortable de ces
situations là mais elle se met vraiment
que ça l'aide seul le restant de mes
jours et que ses termes habitué
et je suis tombé en fait
j'ai eu le droit à tous les conseils et
leur contraire par rapport à ma
poursuite de la pratique du vélo d'hiver
mon commentaire préféré entre tous ayant
été mais le steamer situe au site bébé
comme si ma mort à moi n'étaient pas
suffisamment tragique
donc cet hiver là je me suis acheter des
pneus à clous j'ai continué de rouler
mais ça venait de déclencher la tempête
parfaite d'hormones dans le tapis on se
le cachera pas de soudaine
responsabilité d'un être tout autre à
part entière et surtout
de ce raisonnement que je ne pouvais
plus accepter que mes futurs enfants
vivent dans cette société avec les mêmes
mentalités
j'ai dû accepter que la mobilité dans la
ville
marville n'était pas fait pour les
femmes et lorsque je les anime mais je
me suis demandé comment savait plus
prendre autant de temps dans leur est
élevé pourquoi il serait fait pour les
femmes lorsque historiquement est encore
largement aujourd'hui elle est réfléchie
par des hommes mais ça peut changer on
l'a vu avec les dernières élections
municipales au québec en 2021 une vague
fantastique de femmes élues comme
mairesse et comme conseillère municipale
donc déjà d'avoir des gens différents à
des postes décisionnels
ça peut changer mais seulement si on est
tous conscients en tant que société que
cet enjeu là existe est bien réelle
je vous présente aujourd'hui des pistes
de solutions qui sont absolument
applicable ici comme ailleurs puis ces
pièces de ici on les manque toujours de
ma posture de femmes blanches
trentenaire en santé hétérosexuels donc
sans aucune prétention de répondre à
toutes les vulnérabilités de personnes
qui peuvent être marginalisés
différemment donc avant de vous révéler
ses solutions là je vous fais un bref
portrait de sherbrooke et des
sherbrookoises en moyenne et ce sont des
données qui sont absolument transposable
à toute ville occidentale de taille
moyenne
les chants pourquoi ce gang 80% du
salaire des hommes au niveau de
l'employabilité elles sont davantage à
temps partiel et lorsqu'on les semble
pour la raison principale de ce temps
partiel c'est principalement pour
prendre soin des enfants de la famille
de la communauté donc tout ce qu'on
retrouve dans la sphère du caire el fort
ils sont une cycliste utilitaire pour
cet homme et forment la majorité des
passages dans les transports en commun
tous ces facteurs leur tous ces
paramètres font que la mobilité est
différente les femmes vivent une posture
de sueur mobilité de par leur double
tâche de travail soit le travail du
caire et le travail rémunéré ça lui
réussit donc à ce décès à se déplacer
beaucoup plus souvent que désiré pour
répondre aux besoins de la famille dit
conjoints de la communauté
donc à partir de leurs qu'est ce qu'on
fait mais déjà les femmes en position
décisionnel tel que mentionné c'est un
pas dans la bonne direction un autre
outil à fait efficace et simple est de
faire une analyse différenciée selon le
sexe lorsqu'on mène un projet que ce
soit une réfection des pistes cyclables
un changement d'itinéraire de te bus le
déploiement de vélos en libre service
si ce genre d'outil que permis à la
municipalité de kasugho à en suède c'est
toujours un peu en suède ces initiatives
l'incroyable de faire un changement dans
sa politique de déneigement municipal on
s'entend qui rien de plus n'est qu'une
politique de déneigement l'oustal dans
notre imaginaire et de moins sexy aussi
mais grâce et cette analyse là des
données elle s'est rendu compte que la
façon classique dont elle dénonçait son
réseau affecté davantage les femmes
puisque puisque c'est celle ci qui
utilisaient les trottoirs les vélos et
les voies sécurisées
pour les transports en commun afin
d'aller porter les enfants à l'école et
à la garderie avant même de penser
utiliser les grandes artères pour se
déplacer vers les quartiers de tours à
bureaux de parcs industriels donc en
opérant un 180° la municipalité a
priorisé les trottoirs les pistes
cyclables oui même en hiver on espère
c'est sur brooks ou peu et aussi les
voies de transport en commun ce qui a eu
pour double effet un d'augmenter
l'apport de transport actif ce à quoi on
aurait pu s'attendre son avis jaser
entre nous mais deux ça vraiment réduit
aussi les coûts associés aux chutes et
aux blessures sur glace cook s'est
chiffrée à 2 fois ceux de la voirie en
hiver
c'est aussi ce genre d'initiative
d'analystes différenciée selon les sexes
qui a permis à la société transporte des
mountain pop tard que l'année dernière
de changer sa tarification et sa
réflexion par rapport au trajet même
chose ils ont analysé leur donner dans
kate est une destination se sont rendus
compte que les femmes étaient leur
clientèle principale mais aussi que la
tarification en place les désavantager
puisque les passages étaient payés à la
fois donc à l'entrée ce qu'on retrouve
dans ses origines des destinations dans
les enquêtes l'une des six nations c'est
que majoritairement les déplacements des
hommes de la population active vont
davantage ressemblé à un départ de la
maison du point a vers une arrivée au
point b pour revenir simplement points à
ce qu'on retrouve dans ces mêmes
enquêtes et que les déplacements des
femmes sont davantage étoilé elles vont
parcourir au moins deux kilomètres dans
une même journée mais sur différents
tracés donc on repart du point à de la
maison ont pu déposer quelqu'un que ce
soit un enfant qui se soit repérer dans
qu'on va voir donc au point b aller au
travail au point si souvent profité de
l'heure du lunch pour aller à l'épicerie
rapidement et revenir à la maison donc
ils faisaient que la tarification
étaient exorbitantes et absolument non
inclusive en changeant leur tarification
vers un truc uniformiser qui se
calculent et seul donc s'en ajoutent
deux charge mentale la société
transports a non seulement favoriser les
déplacements étoiles et des femmes mais
évidemment c'est toute la population qui
en bénéficient
donc on voit que oui la politique de
déneigement municipal oui la
tarification des autobus mais si on y
réfléchit
les chaises la hauteur des marges mais
ce qu'elle est conforme ce sont des
normes des objets qui ont été réfléchies
selon notre homme type moyen donc on
parle ici d'un spécimen d'un mètre 70 76
kg avec vous le remarquerez des tibias
parfaitement lié pour une hauteur de
service conforme à 45 cm de hauteur
les municipalités vont même jusqu à
réfléchir le temps de traverse d'un feu
piéton sur cet homme type moyen excluant
donc d'emblée toute une frange de la
population beaucoup plus vulnérables
merci
donc ces exclusions sont un peu partout
sans qu'on y réfléchisse ce sont des
normes qu'on a adopté ce sont comme les
tests de collision routière vous savez
lire lorsqu'une voiture heurte très vite
armure avec deux mannequins en
styromousse on note un autre matériau à
l'intérieur est bien c'est que dans la
dernière décennie que la grande-bretagne
imposer aux constructeurs américains
d'intégrer des mannequins femmes dans
ces tests de collision donc bien sûr les
constructeurs donc que printems type
moyens et on en fait une version réduite
comme si les femmes n'étaient qu'une
version réduite de la masculinité et
donc sans penser que la densité osseuse
l'espacement des vertèbres les
proportions de fait différente mais de
toute manière il utilise le mannequin
femme que principalement sur le siège du
passager donc les données qui en
ressortent sont insécure pour la
majorité d'entre nous selon la société
de l'assurance automobile du québec bien
que les femmes soient beaucoup moins
impliqués dans des accidents graves de
la route nous avons 50 % plus de chances
d'être gravement blessé et 17% plus de
chances d'en mourir puisque bien sûr les
tests de collision reprennent nothum
type moyen de mettre 70 76 kg avec des
tibias permettant une assise confortable
à 45 cm de hauteur
une dernière exclusion sur laquelle on
pourrait collectivement agir est plutôt
symbolique mais ça de la toponymie donc
à sherbrooke 50% de nos noms de rues de
pont de parcs viennent de personnages
publics ou historiques on peut penser au
coin de rue papineau mairie ou devant le
restaurant chez louis j'ai reçu ma
demande en mariage
or may cry si l'ironie du sort et je
parle peu le de seulement les battements
de bastide il ya 200 ans les femmes
étaient complètement un visibiliser des
sphères publiques je vous parle de la
dernière parution sur le site de la
commission de la toponymie du québec où
le pont était honorée à monsieur gilbert
desrosiers
avec comme mention un citoyen engagé
dans sa communauté donc j'ai aucun doute
que je le bar était incroyable mais
vraiment il y avait aucun pendant
féminin qui auraient pu faire pencher la
balance des villes moyennes québécoise
où 90% des noms de rues portant l'autre
personne fond masculin
toutes les femmes vont être exclues de
ces noms-là de pont de rues de park
semble normal que les terrains du ne
nous appartient pas mais ça peut
tellement changé on a des solutions qui
nous apparaissent en une collectivité
qui se mobilisent ça peut changer mais
seulement avec l'aide de tout le monde
d'entre nous
y travaillons ensemble pour que les
générations futures ne puisse plus faire
le lien entre le banc de bus le temps de
traverse un flux piétons et la politique
de déneigement municipal comme étant
axée autour de l'homme blanc moyen d'un
mètre 70 76 kg avec des tibias répondant
à une hauteur de 45 cm mise sur un
collectif ne représentant davantage
ayons la créativité la bienveillance de
transformer nos municipalités pour que
plus personne n'est a faussement mettre
des écouteurs le soir pour se sentent en
sécurité a payé trop cher ses transports
en commun ou a décliné de demande en
mariage de bord de lui
[Applaudissements]